so guys I'm gonna get straight into it
obviously there's this tweet that's
going around and obviously I need to
clarify certain things I can tell you
exactly what happened to the accident
you know you know with that female you
know I was feeling a bit depressed that
day you know it's a bit lonely
it was hard times for me was hard times
for me no I wasn't married then you know
as human beings you know we all have
needs so you know you know I just you
know I just I just slipped up are you
dizzy
you think I'm poor bowden gonna go
sexually harass people now I wonder if
something really clear and when you guys
to understand because these moves that's
been happening recently and hope you
guys know this tweet that was tweeted
from a weird maybe this whoever Muslim
one should cause her page she opened a
pigeon flip in November she's about five
fifteen pictures yeah and you know
what's funny yeah Tommy Robinson tweeted
this right now I want to say thank you
guys him Tommy Robinson is literally in
fear let me tell you guys why yeah
recently since this whole poor coding
this bring first thing happened how I
went there you know how she would act in
militant you know being violent with me
except I didn't allow me to speak then I
went again to the police station as you
can see here she starts crying and came
out dramatic and that I understand after
that happened I send out the Tommy
Robinson yeah and he knows what's
happening he knows his time is up
intellectually is finished for him you
know because he knows that as a Muslim
you tube and overlooks one who follows
the Quran and the Sunnah to the tea
everything yeah he's not shamed of his
religion who is not apologetic I'm not
here to sugarcoat my religion and by the
way this is Habibi
yeah so it doesn't say jihad no it
doesn't say a cocky or anyone no no calm
down yeah you know what's really close
you guys please this get is carefully
how is it that Tommy Robinson ends up
finding these new accounts
I'm only new accounts that comes across
them yeah I'd be surprised if he makes
them himself here I just want to know
something there how does Tony Robinson
come across these weird tweets like how
it's not gonna probe in this news piece
but he's not following the person yeah
so and it's a new accounts from November
so how does Tony Robinson find this
tweet randomly
retweet it without nobody even tagging
him say oh look I need our apparently
asked the size of a brothel woman and
tried to sexually assault her I'm the
poor Goulding sorry I'm not married so
how does he come across this unless he
is the one who got somebody to make that
account or he himself has made that
account for him to be aware of that
tweet yeah and he retweets it now look
at the desperation guys two days ago he
was talking about the video that I did
about the sister who was twerking and it
was video done and he's even trying to
twist that to say you made him cry just
like how Maginot was tried by backfired
on it didn't work it because that
sister's family got in contact with me
twerking and I did an interview with her
and a family thanked me for stopping the
bullying and trying to get those videos
down because the sister was distressed
yeah okay and he's not Oh Muslims having
a big do for a guilt working excuse me
excuse me we have our beliefs yeah
nobody says bully her what she did was
wrong difficult to the Orthodox
community here you yeah you know the
ones you know science we found you and I
dare you to go through all four this
community here and see a Jewish girl
twerking and let's see what the Jewish
community does of course it can be
outraged of course they are
why is speaking just about Muslims why
don't you go to this hurry hurry to
community in Stamford ooh yeah and do
the scene with them you go and question
them you wouldn't you can see the
desperation when somebody's scared or
when somebody's cornered what did they
do what did they do when they can't
address your points and your issue what
did they do they start personally
attacking you at hominins yeah they
start saying you're like this look at
you you know look at your your face look
at your nose look at you can see when
they can't address your issue and they
know Tommy Robinson knows it's night
night for him
it is Jen as a time you know denies a
lot but janazah yeah that means I was
great by the way calm down yeah it's Jen
a certain genetic means it's your
intellectual funeral funeral image
gentleman through here Tommy I'm telling
you me I will come wherever you like
lunch on me holla yeah if you want you
can have your bacon another my halal
chicken or the veggie share in these
days
anytime anyplace I dare you I think
that's already big let's no discussion
using your friends book which I'm gonna
be bunk can you believe it all Sweden is
friends book here called my Muslim to
kill for Islamiyah Muhammad's Quran and
I've got PDF oh by the way no way I'm
paying for that hell no especially with
the reviews I'm gonna show you some of
the reviews yeah you would laugh yet off
you will laugh at his movies yeah and I
couldn't believe it the nonce that's on
it yeah I've got Muslim saved for when I
meet Tommy
but this specially want if you read the
Quran chronologically in invoice chances
if you read it in front of front about
back to front backwards you see that
Islam is promoting killing I didn't know
if I should laugh or cry at that
statement I go for a little break to
Dubai literally absolute joke so what
I'm gonna do is guys as you guys know
this tweet is fake you know it's big
yeah I'm gonna come and sixty I saw you
in public asked for your bra size who
the hell asked hi I'm Adam here just
wanted to know please forgive me yeah
just
and by the way aggressively yeah and
what's your bra size tell me the bra
size now I want to know it turns me on
tell me your bra size what was that what
the hell are you talking about yeah
like I said before guys this is nonsense
rubbish as you guys know I'm not doing
this beautiful clarification I'm doing
this video to show Tommy Robinson is
shook he is scared this is an official
challenge I dare you to debate me on
this topic this is sample more Tara
I dare and challenge you I challenge you
yeah we're gonna use your friends book I
tell you Mimi I've been asking for a
long time you avoiding me you don't you
mean you don't meet me this is an invite
let's have a debate this have a
discussion it's not to me I will track
you down I will find you
and when I find you I am going to
install all the Commission Thomas
panatela embarrass you with your own
friends book he's got your name on it
yeah your friend rice book oh you have
done is copy and paste in the Quran go
your friend to write a few things yeah
which I saw was a student comedy a joke
and you just put a name in it that's all
you've done if that means you're writing
books fam I'm telling you I'm going to
publish all kind of books you know get
people to write a copy paste and put my
name on it your fans and people that
watch my stuff they want
discussion happened take a good look at
this face me because you are in
Charlotte Allah with the permission of
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala yeah
the own merciful the most mighty yeah
the one that we worship yeah I would
eventually meet you for a discussion and
I will challenge you in all your points
yeah save yourself embarrassment and
let's do this if not I'll see you soon
mate
goodbye Salaam alaikum what's your bra
size